alors Gabriel vous avez d'autres idées
de sortie à nous proposer pour les
vacances de Noël on commence par quoi et
bien je vous emmène célébrer Noël dans
nos monuments ivelinois vous ne risquez
pas de perdre des points cette fois
Grégory pas de souci à l'occasion des
fêtes de fin d'année l'événement compte
et histoire proposé par le Centre des
monuments nationaux revient au programme
spectacle visite animation dans les
ivelines trois monuments sont concernés
le château de maison à maison la fite
propose à ses visite inclu dos géant
accompagné de spectacle de son côté le
Château de Rambouillet célèbre le nouvel
an en compte et en musique à pois c'est
la Villa Savoie qui se transforme en
boîte à jeu pour l'occasion pour en
savoir plus sur le programme détaillé
rendez-vous sur le site internet
monument-nationaux.fr à 50 an nieline
souffle aussi un air de Noël puisque le
musée de la ville qui est installé à
Montini le Bretonneux s'illumine pour
les fêt oui pour les vacances de Noël le
réseau des médiathèques et le musée de
la ville ont conccté un programme festif
le thème cette année la lumière en lien
avec l'exposition actuelle du musée de
la ville les allumés du design alors
vous pourrez créer vos propres lampions
et photofor de Noël ça peut donner des
idées de cadeaux et et de quoi illuminer
certainement aussi vos tables pour les
fêtes tout ça sur un air de Noël en plus
il vous accompagne voilà pour donner un
air de Noël a un petit truc alors si on
veut aussi compléter sa décoration pour
Noël Gabriel il y a des ateliers
créatifs qui sont proposés pendant les
vacances au musée Maurice Denis oui
cette fois ça se passe au Musée
départemental de Saint-Germain au lait
qui propose de redécouvrir le musée et
son exposition Maurice Denis les chemins
de la nature jusqu'au 5 janvier des
ateliers sont proposés au cours de la
visite alors parmi eux vous l'avez dit
création de cartes de vœux art décoratif
ou encore dessin certains ateliers sont
accessibles dès 4 ans sur réservation un
bon moyen de mêler la culture et les
loisirs créatifs celle-ci je l'avais
reconnu si vous avez un petit TER de
station d'iver oui c'était dou nuit si
vous avez un petit TER de station
d'hiver bah vous pouvez le faire
maintenant parce que on va changer de
décor à Mantel jolie la commune
justement se transforme en une station
de sport
d'hiver oui tout à fait Grégory patinoir
ok sur glace curling ou encore snowpk et
mur d'escalade de glace tout ça ça se
passe dans les ivelines c'est ce que
propose le village sport d'hiver de
Montel jolie jusqu'au 6 janvier audelà
des sports d'hiver c'est toute
l'ambiance de Noël qui j'étais pas prête
à l'arrêt c'est inédit idé de sorti avec
de la flute de
P Noël donc qui s'installe sur le
village au programme également des
champs de Noël une parade ou encore un
spectacle lumineux c'est l'ambiance
d'une véritable station de ski et on
termine vos idées de sortie Gabriel avec
un spectacle FÉRIQUE au château de
Versailles oui à l'occasion des fêtes de
fin d'année le château de Versailles
propose une plongée dans l'atmosphère
baroque du château au travers d'une
visite spectacle du salon d'Hercule à la
chambre de la reine en passant par la
Galerie des Glaces vous suivrez
comédiens danseurs et chanteurs pour un
show féérique une immersion dans le
versaill baroque de l'époque et ces
soirées d'exception on regarde un
extrait
et vous l'avez vu sur les images le Père
Noël du château aussi et de la partie un
père Noël h style baroque bien
évidemment merci beaucoup Gabriel bravo
en tout cas d'avoir gardé votre
concentration pendant ces idées de sorti
estce qu'autour de la table il y a des
idées qui vous intéressent est- que vous
qu'est-ce que vous avez prévu de faire
pendant les fêtes Sophie euh quelque
chose d'assez d'assez simple en famille
mais c'est vrai que le château de
Versaille là ça me dit bien ça m'attire
oua a réservé quand même oui je pense
qu'il va y avoir du monde Clara elle est
d'accord j'ai l'ession ouais ouais ça a
l'air vachement chouette franchement
pourquoi pas et en face château de
versaill et pourquoi pas aussi le zo
toiri vous m'avez donné envie tout à
l'heure aussi je vais peut-être y
retourner ça peut être sympa ouis aussi
George Smith j'habite à quelques
kilomètres du château de versa enfin les
clés sous bois c'est pas très loin le
château de versaill fait l'unanimité oui
j'ai l'impression c'est quand même un
symbole dans les ivelines et
effectivement le le château de
Versailles ça ça parle à tout le monde